c'est toujours un sujet extrêmement
passionnant quand une marque t'on koné
se lance de nouveaux défis et part dans
autre chose jusqu'en 2018
on avait un modèle suivie d'un modèle tu
es un modèle plus évolué à partir de
2019 on a eu deux modèles en début
d'année modèle standard plus beau d'être
professionnel et ensuite les modalités
qui ont suivi le one piece est telle au
one piece est écroué à partir cette
année on est effectivement hull one + 8
le one + 8 pro on devrait voir arriver à
la fin de l'année les hommes +8 et one
plus futés pros et on s'attendait à un
mois de plus z
un one plus light on ne savait pas
réellement que ça allait être est il est
arrivé ici c'est le one + nerd alors
c'est vachement intéressant parce que
d'un point de vue purement stratégie de
marque
ce que nous dessine moi une place ici
c'est tout simplement une évolution de
sa gamme rien de bien révolutionnaire
parce que plein de marques le fond mais
de la part d'une puce c'est très
intéressant quand on regarde leur
histoire wyplosz est arrivé en disant
une place en plus j'ai encore comment
vous le dites moi je veux dire one place
ou en plus donc ça change dans la vidéo
d'ailleurs dit moi que vous ont pas en
commentaire comment vis tu es d'ailleurs
puisque j'en ai la et juste avant de
commencer et n'hésitez pas bien vous
abonner en cliquant sur petits boutons
que vous avez là pour tout savoir sur
l'actualité dans le monde d'ordinateurs
de bon usage de votre vie numérique vous
habite amené à cliquer sur le petit
bouton rouge accéder la cloche comme ça
vous serez notifié dès qu'une nouvelle
vidéo arrivants ce qui est intéressant
avec le nouveau modèle c'est que one
plus élargi sa gamme
quand on sait faire le très haut de
gamme on s'est fatalement faire le
milieu de gamme et il pourrait savoir
faire s'il le souhaitait d'entrée gamme
et je leur ai posé la question et on dit
que pour l'instant c'était pas à l'ordre
du jour quand une marque commune place
arrive sur un tout nouveau produit comme
celui-là ça demande quand même des
investissements assez colossaux il ya
donc trois modèles distincts au
catalogue de one place en 2020 avec
celui là c'est le one plus mornes et le
one plus mornes
il est intéressant parce qu'il s'adresse
à une cible beaucoup plus large que le
one + 8 et one + 8 pro qui sont des
modèles très haut de gamme plus pour les
technophiles ce qu'ils veulent ce qui se
fait de mieux
je le dôme vous dire ce que je pense
vous donner mon retour sur ce one plus
mornes
est ce qu'il est intéressant est ce
qu'il est fait pour vous est-ce qu'il
faut se positionner et ce que soient vos
pour diramba en commentaire vous ce que
vous en pensez
comment l'usagé numéro un coin me
retrouver là dessus c'est effectivement
la partie multimédia et ça qui est
intéressant tout de suite je vous le dis
il ya un truc que je suis pas
extrêmement fine et j'ai déjà dit
notamment lorsqu'on veut plus a fait le
choix d'abandonner sa caméra pop up pour
venir mettre ici
les petites bulles des petites encoches
on perd le gain qu'on avec le one + 7
pro 1 grand écran dégagé de toute
contrainte est ici c'est exactement la
même chose peut-être moins être
problématique puisque on est sur un
smartphone milieu de gamme et pas sur du
très haut de gamme mais je trouve une
fois de plus que vous allez regarder un
film une série du contenu multimédia
jouets et bien vous avez cette espèce de
grande de bus grands dans coach qui est
là
j'ai conscience que nous sommes en 2020
qu'en 2020 et bien il faut faire des
choix et qu'on n'a pas encore
aujourd'hui des caméras qu'on peut
intégrer sous l'écran qui viendront
invisible ça arrivera dans les années à
venir mais pour l'instant ce n'est pas
encore le cas
je me accommode mais lorsque je regarde
des vidéos et bien mon regard ne peut
s'empêcher en tout cas dès le départ dès
les premières minutes d'être attirés ici
et il trouve que c'est un peu dommage
ce que je dis là est très vrai pour le
très haut de gamme et un peu moins pour
le milieu de gamme parce que le milieu
de gamme forcément il faut faire des
choix il faut faire des coupes
budgétaires il faut choisir des techno
qui vont être intéressantes mais qui
vont pas coûter très cher pour rester
compétitif donc pour un smartphone de
2020 c'est pas déconner one place en
plus est venu vraiment lutter ici
bon pourquoi pas ça c'était le petit
point de départ une fois qu'on oublie ce
point l'écran est vraiment de bonne
qualité je vous ai des volets la fiche
technique dans la vidéo donne boxing day
parvient sultan qui est intéressant à
savoir c'est que vous avez vraiment très
très bel écran amoled de 6 44 pouces et
un point qui est extrêmement intéressant
c'est que vous avez un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 alors 90 c'était
sur le haut de gamme l'année dernière
chez one plus notamment sur le 7 pro
vous retrouver exactement la même chose
cette année dans le milieu de gamme chez
one plus donc ça s'est vraiment bien je
trouve que l'écran est plutôt bien
calibré alors après à vous de voir ce
que vous préférez entre vifs naturel
j'aime bien les deux villes est un petit
peu plus criard un peu plus pétant sur
les couleurs j'aurais tendance à aimer
un peu plus de naturel si vous
connaissez oxygène os sur les
smartphones de one peut se trouver
exactement la même chose ici vous avez
un mode lecture manie nuit pouvait avoir
un effet couleurs vives enfin il ya pas
mal de deux possibilités de petites
choses qui pouvaient venir coacher un os
qui fonctionnera parfaitement bien qui
est basé sur un android disent vous avez
lezennes mode le dark mode l'expérience
logiciel est donc vraiment très très
cool pour tous vos usages pour tout ce
que vous allez en faire vous avez votre
tiroir d'application c'est clair c'est
lisible c'est bien du point de vue
purement expérientiel là-dessus j'aime
beaucoup le choix fait une place sur cet
écran est intéressant parce qu'il vient
répondre à trois usages essentiels quand
tout cas moi je vais vraiment identifier
là dessus le premier usage ça va être la
partie vision
deux vidéos l'aspect multimédia que vous
regardez des vidéos sur netflix amazon
prime 10 mai + youtube ou ce que vous
voulez vous avez un écran qualité à
noter qu'ici vous avez uniquement haut
parleur mono mais sur du milieu de gamme
c'est pas des anges en est pas
surprenant et vous avez un son qui somme
toute assez de qualité jamais dans
quelques instants
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point ça va être la party gaming qui est
extrêmement importante aujourd'hui parce
qu'on sait que c'est un des usages qui
montent en flèche et de plus en plus
vous avez derrière un processeur qui et
milieu de gamme mais qui est performant
c'est le snapdragon 765 gg pour gaming
avec un peu plus de performances et qui
marchera parfaitement bien c'est un
socle y ait cinq jeux qui vous permettra
donc d'avoir la 5g déclin ce lundi et
sera éligible dans votre pays et que
vous aurez souscrit un abonnement 5 jets
d'eau en tout cas il est prêt pour la 5g
vous avez en plus 8 gigas de ram qui va
venir apporter de la fluidité la techno
drame c'est de la lp dédièrent 4x ça ira
très très bien vous pouvez également
monter jusqu'à 12 giga de ram si vous
voulez vraiment aller plus loin en
termes de fluidité et de gaming mais
déjà 8 gigas de ram ça ira très bien et
vous avez en stockage soit 128 soit 256
go de stockage onu fs 2.7 un grand stand
à tout ça non extensible alors déjà 128
jia de stockage je pense que vous avez
de quoi faire 256 vous faire plaisir
vous avez donc la config 8 moussan 28-12
plus de 156 à vous de voir d'ailleurs
dit moi vous est-ce que 128 giga du
stockage non extensible ça vous paraître
suffisant ou est ce que vous pensez
qu'il faut monter à 250 idiot déstockage
marqué le mois en bas en commentaire
donc on est quoi faire en terme de
performance on a un processeur qui est
suffisamment puissant sans en faire trop
on n'est pas sur le sens dragon 865 y
est le plus haut de gamme de qualcomm et
qu'il ira beaucoup plus loin
mais ce que vous avez là pour les trois
quarts des usages pour cette cible plus
grand public est un peu moins
technophiles qu'il va chercher une place
là dessus eh bien il faut une
proposition qui est vraiment d'être donc
ton la party gaming ça marche et
troisième visage qui est important est
très important aujourd'hui c'est toute
la question des réseaux sociaux parce
qu'on est très souvent son nom réseaux
sociaux à venir consulter du contenu que
ce soit sur instagram sur tik tok et
compagnie on vient voir ce qui se
passait il fait d'abord un écran avec un
taux de rafraîchissement de 90 ans
eh bien ça vous apporte de la fluidité
du confort de visionnage donc voyez 90
ans répond vraiment cette problématique
des réseaux sociaux mais également à la
question du gaming
donc on a un smartphone qui est
polyvalent pour l'univers multimédia qui
vient cocher des cases et qui marche
très très bien
un peu surprenant c'est que voyez par
exemple je me suis mis un film sur
netflix et bien lorsque je le pousse en
plein écran il n'ya pas jusqu'au bout
ici il vient bien au bout sur le banc
mais pas sur le haut donc il s'étire pas
à fond ça ne fait pas partout parce que
sur youtube ça vient vraiment les tirs à
fond et là ça fonctionne et ça me fait
la même chose sur des films sur my canal
donc je peux pas vous expliquer pourquoi
la partie audio il coule vous avez un
haut parleur mono qui si tu lis ici pas
et autant à leur siano il ya de la
puissance lorsque vous le pousser à fond
ça va prendre un petit peu à tordre mais
c'est pas anormal sorte je veux dire
ceinture et bien évidemment vous venez
de baisser et vous profitez d'une
expérience qui est relativement bonne le
spel très sage c'est la rejette
complètement si d'un côté on est sur un
smartphone donc c'est pas anormal mais
si vous voulez aller plus loin je vous
invite à venir découvrir les nouveaux
buzz de wyplosz nouveau et premier belge
de wyplay ce qui vient de se positionner
directement dans vos oreilles se sont
pas des intra mais ça fonctionne bien il
s'avère extrêmement facilement le fonds
est assez qualitatif on n'est pas sur un
truc complètement incroyable mais ça
marche bien l'autonomie est bonne lors
des appels vous avez une réduction de
bruit environnantes alors ça va pas
venir vous isolez mais ça vient couper
un petit peu le son extérieur pour les
personnes que vous allez avoir au bout
du fil
j'aime bien la proposition je trouve
jolie alors moi j'ai pris en bleu et je
trouve pas mal kong mx1 smartphones qui
est plutôt tout cet écran 90 eur htva
vraiment venir apporter en terme de
fluidité lorsque vous allez jouer à
différents jeux ça c'est vraiment mais
vraiment appréciable
et ça ce matin qu'il faut absolument que
vous veniez protégé puisque vous avez un
dos qui est très très joli mais ça
serait dommage de venir l'abîmé même si
vous avez un corps gorilla glass 5 à
l'avant et à l'arrière il faut quand
même faire attention et je vous invite à
venir découvrir l'école de mon
partenaire inochi coque à l'arrière
solide suite mais également une
protection d'écran à l'avant pour venir
complètement protégé votre smartphone je
vous ai mis le lien en bas dans la
description en passant par mon lien vous
avez une remise pour venir acheter votre
coque et votre protection d'écran au
meilleur prix ça c'est très bien vous
avez plusieurs modèles plusieurs choix
rhinochill propose une gamme qui est
très large
personnalisable vous avez est à dire
cliquez sur le lien en bas pour le
découvrir comme ça vous allez pouvoir
habiller votre fois de plus l'ordre de
la meilleure façon qui soit avoir un
smartphone qui est performant un
smartphone qui est adapté pour les
réseaux sociaux pour le gaming pour le
multimédia
c'est bien mais ce qu'on veut c'est que
nos smartphones ils durent dans le temps
on veut pas le recharger tous les jours
one + a également répondu à cette
problématique avec une grosse batterie
de 4000 115 millions terreur faut être
extrêmement précis si vous avez
de l'a26 charge 30 pour venir recharger
rapidement 2 0 à 50 % en 30 minutes
autant dire que si vous arrivez à un
moment à court de batterie et bien voulu
charger ne serait-ce qu'un quart d'heure
vingt minutes pour pouvoir repartir très
facilement et je vous dis en une
demi-heure de recharge et bien vous êtes
partie facilement pour une journée
d'utilisation parce que oui ce
smartphone vous allez pouvoir le garder
entre une journée à deux journées une
fois de plus et je le dis et je le
répète en fonction de vous de vos usages
de ce que vous allez en faire il n'y a
pas de magie au niveau des smartphones
même si vous avez une belle batterie de
4115 millan paire eur si vous êtes tous
tant de fougue toute la journée en train
de jouer en train de visionner des
séries en train de faire des photos est
en train de les partager sur les réseaux
sociaux au bout d'un moment votre
batterie et tiendra mais ça deviendrait
un peu faiblard puisque je trouve
rassurant avec qu'il avait un petit h 30
c'est que vous le branchez vous allez
faire deux trois petits trucs vous
revenez et hop vous êtes parti pour une
journée donc ça s'est vraiment bien
à noter qu'ici je vous l'avais dit heure
de lunch boxing vous n'avez pas de
recharge sans fil mais sur du milieu de
gamme s'est pas non plus qu'on a
recherché il ya un autre point que
j'aime bien et qui est vraiment lié à la
partie de l' os c'est le logiciel au
niveau de la photo je trouve extrêmement
intuitif regarder pouvez switcher
facilement entre vos différents modes et
là vous passez sur le zoom numérique x 2
puisque vous êtes sur la caméra de 48
mégapixels vous laissez votre doigt
appuyé vous et votre petite molette pour
monter jusqu'aux zoom numérique x 10
c'est intuitif on voit tout de suite où
est ce qu'on est
c'est très cool vous pas senti de son
ultra grand-angle et j'adore l'idée de
cette petite molette pareil pour le
choix de vos modes portrait paysage
nocturne professionnels pour trouver
tous très très facilement vous avez de
la vidéo super stabilisé si vous
souhaitez enfin pour ça je vous à dire
tout expliqué lors de la vidéo d'un
boxing et vous avez vos autres modes qui
sont en dessous pourrait venir découvrir
il est l'heure de jeter un coup d'oeil
du côté des photos alors ça c'est les
photos plutôt coucher de soleil ça
marche bien je vais vous montrer un peu
dans l'ensemble pour que voici est
vraiment une idée déjà une différence de
colorimétrie entre le capteur principal
e 48 mégapixels et l'ultra grand temps
que vous allez le voir sur des photos en
plein jour c'est pas trés déconnant mais
bon ça fonctionne on se rapproche avec
le x 2 c passable c'est pas
extraordinaire mais ça marchera et quand
vous allez jusqu'au 10 je vous dis tout
de suite c'est absolument inexploitables
c'est même très très moche on arrive sur
des photos de nuit alors vous la photo
de nuit elle fait le taf on arrive à
sortir des choses mais c'est pas
extraordinaire s'en veut de la bonne
photo denis shiuan plus il faut aller
sur le web +8 procès là vous aurez le
meilleur résultat on arrive quand même à
voir le ciel étoilé
on voit bien le
google s'est pas couché de soleil c'est
effectivement la lune et stan lumière
qui sont un peu trop poussée sur l'ultra
grand angle en un bonne nuit mais c'est
pas extraordinaire ne soit pas du tout
il ya pas mal de l'aberration à droite à
gauche c'est pas ouf on arrive quand
même à sortir quelques petites choses
c'est un peu poussif mais malgré tout ça
donne quelques résultats qui sont assez
sympa et qui fonctionne dans l'ensemble
pour quelques petits souvenirs
on a réalisé sur les photos prises en
plein jour alors ici les conditions sont
vraiment exceptionnelles on est en plein
été il fait beau il fait chaud va tout
de suite la différence de colorimétrie
entre le capteur principal est ensuite
son ultra grand-angle ya un côté un peu
plus le un peu plus violine pardon on le
voit très très bien ici voyez lui très
grand-angle caméra principale c'est
beaucoup plus violine c'est très bizarre
on le voit comme ça d'ailleurs sur cet
éphémère et dès qu'on se rapproche avec
le x 2 ça ira et dès qu'on s'approche au
x 10 c'est pas terrible terrible caméra
principale ultra grand-angle de plus on
est sur du vieux lille fois deux fois
dix c'est pas beau du tout mais bon dans
l'ensemble on a un résultat qui est
somme toute assez correct et qui
fonctionne il en descend la macro alors
bon la macro mais je ne suis pas
extraordinairement fans mais ça fera le
taf
après tout pourquoi pas pour continuer
caméra principale ultra-grand-angle x 2
x 5 et x 10 pour moi le mieux c'est
passé deux fois deux fois ça qu'on perd
un petit peu il faut ni c'est pas
extraordinaire
on va parler maintenant de la caméra de
celle créée en caméra de celle-ci - elle
me pose un peu question parce que vous
avez deux possibilités vous êtes sur une
focale un peu standard on passe ensuite
sur un ultra grand-angle et damien
espèce de voile blanc et j'arrive pas à
savoir pourquoi alors effectivement une
différence de colorimétrie entre les
deux mais bon c'est pas très dérangeant
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'à cet effet
voile blanc il voulait retrouver un peu
de tous les côtés je trouve ça pas
terrible là il ya une espèce
d'aberration qu'on va retrouver aussi au
niveau de l'inscription sur le tee shirt
qu'on a par ailleurs voyez c'est très
bizarre
j'arrive pas soir pourquoi idée qu'on
repasse sur le capteur principal à
l'arrière du smartphone est bien là par
contre le rendu est vraiment bien
meilleur le mode portrait aussi assez
surprenant vous avez deux possibilités
soit vous êtes sur la focale principal
ça vous passez sur un ultra grand-angle
et bien voyez il a du mal avec le haut
des doigts que ce soit sur un fond de
roche ou sur un un fonds de derb et bien
c'est pas extraordinaire
j'ai du mal à comprendre pourquoi et
quand vous passez sur l' ultra grand
angle est bien là par contre c'est tout
de suite beaucoup mieux et la
colorimétrie vraiment respecté il des
tours bien les doigts d'un côté comme de
l'autre pouvoir vous n'avez pas de
caméra tough dans l'absolu le rang du
haut niveau la photo est bon au niveau
du capteur principal le rendu
la vidéo va fonctionner on peut switcher
on va toujours la différence de
colorimétrie entre le capteur principal
ultra grand-angle et lorsqu'on vient
zoomer en x 2 on va pas avoir ce qu'il
ya de mieux mais pour quelques souvenirs
une fois de plus un fera très très bien
la faire vous voyez là ce n'est plus du
tout dans l'idée du flagship killer
whale plus v s'amuse arrive sur autre
chose sur ce modèle là on reste bien
évidemment dans ce que sait faire one
plus sur le one plus one plus fluide pro
et tremblements la voiture suite et ils
ont une puce suite tu es pro un peu plus
tard dans l'année la deuxième partie de
l'année mais sandra par alternance
ailleurs abonnés vont maintenant si vous
voulez tout savoir comme ça vous serez
au courant de tout owen plus évolué il
n'y a pas un changement on reste
vraiment dans la même idée il évolue
avec ce modèle là moi ce que je trouve
intéressant déjà c'est tout le travail
marketing qui est fait autour de ce
nouveau modèle de cette nouvelle
référence
l'identité de marque est toujours très
très très fort chez one plus l'idée de
se dire ok on va lancer à faire une
présentation débloqués par le comité va
le faire en réalité augmentée c'est un
gros challenge toute la stratégie mise
en place derrière pour faire découvrir
ce produit avec un nouveau compte
instagram et tout ce qu'on peut voir
partout
et bien c'est très malin ça marche bien
il reste dans sa cote est très innovant
et en apportant de par cette image à
côté prévient mal en produits il n'est
pas réellement premium parce qu'on est
dans le milieu de gamme
on a néanmoins une très belle fiche
technique avec un smartphone qui est
très solide et des choix qui sont
assumés et maîtrisée notamment le fait
d'avoir choisi plutôt le capteur 48
mégapixels de sony envie d'aller sur le
64 mégapixels parce que il le trouvait
meilleur en termes de photos il ya donc
des choix il ya un vrai parti pris effet
un smartphone qui est bien que je peux
vous conseiller s'il vous intéresse
parce qu' ils répondent à pas mal
d'usagers il ya ce petit bémol que je
vais venir apporter au niveau de l'écran
lorsque vous allez venir regarder votre
contenu sur netflix ou my canal avec
cette bande noire que vous avez l'âme
d'un autre côté vos caméras là votre
bulle votre poisson ne vient pas vous
embêter donc bon ça et créer un espèce
de déséquilibre mais bon on voit le
contenu on s'y habitue donc c'est pas
très très grave
c'est un smartphone honnête que j'aime
bien et que je vous recommande surtout
sur la config 8 +128 parce qu'il est
intéressant il est à 399 euros
un tout petit peu moins de 400 euros
puisque la version 12 plus de 156 est à
499 et là je me poserai davantage de
questions pourquoi parce que si vous
regardez sur le site de rennes place
d'ailleurs vous aimez les liens en bas
dans la description vous avez lu juan
plus le one plus one plus one plus one +
7 pro
que j'ai adoré que j'ai beaucoup plus
utilisé l'année dernière qui à 549 c'est
à dire que à 50 euros des cas ça reste
de l'argent 50 euros mais à 50 euros
d'écart vous pouvez partir sur le one +
7 pro qu'il ya un processeur qui sera
pas de la dernière génération mais qui
reste un des derniers processeurs n'est
plus haut de gamme de qualcomm et qui
marche très bien c'est le 855 que vous
avez surtout un grand écran cent en
poche ce qui n'est pas le cas ici vous
avez une caméra pop up il est un peu
plus lourd mais il est très bien très
puissant très performant il marche bien
et moi je m'aime beaucoup
donc voyez à 50 euros d'écart la
question se pose donc la guerre sont
douces plus de temps 56 il faut vraiment
le vouloir
la version 8 +128 pour moi oui pour moi
oui elle est vraiment très très cool et
je peux vous le recommander à vous de
dire vous maintenant ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire comment
retrouver souvent plus nord est ce qu'il
vous plaît est ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter
est-ce que vous attendriez 1 - 2 + nord
de 2 deuxième génération qui pourrait
arriver qu'il arriverait je pense à des
prochaines et puis qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ces petits bugs moi je trouve
assez cool très pratique
j'aime bien ce côté en plus moi j'ai
pris couleur bleu klein vraiment très
très cool dit de moi tout ce que vous en
pensez
en bas on commente agra l'on se trouve
extrêmement rapidement parce qu'on a
plein de belles choses à se raconter
bon on va beaucoup d'amour a très vite
twitter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]